big flo et oli ils sont venus chercher
kenji au bureau et le pauvre kenji il
croyait qu'il allait faire un kiff est
en fête
babar big flo et oli réunis sur un bail
c'est jamais très bon à regarder mon
frérot je t'explique quelque chose c'est
que moi j'ai un kill dans la vie c'est
que quand tu kiffes j'ai envie de te
faire qu'il fait tout le temps tu vas
voir
j'étais préparé une surprise et déçue de
la turbie les flowlines belles surprises
sont autant j'espère tu vas beaucoup la
scala dans la voiture là il ya 80% des
ventes de disques en france il faut
commander un truc
dis moi on m'a emmené dans un endroit et
tout ce que tu nous promettent que tu
chanteras quelles que soient les
circonstances
quoi qu'il a une chance est vrai ben
vas-y je vous promets
bisous ces êtres humains deuxième fois
saluer francs
je suis inquiet pour kenji ont fait ça
quand dans les avions ouais il faut que
tu m'aides ça allait frérot fait nous
comprenons pas ce que je vais ça c'est
qu'on a très loin de là quoi qu'il
arrive il fournit chante quelque chose
dans stressé on parle à l'air c'est
inacceptable
à lire une partie cas les tricks et les
gars je vous vois pas j'ai envie de
lever près van la parra auteur
[Musique]
ça y est les gaffes à ta tête
vas-y là tu l'as tu as la voiture même
aller
[Musique]
bonds est vraiment près romont kenzy
pouvoir lever
ça appartient de leurs tyrans cascadeur
et baba pour le coup champions va vous
être et tout le monde les gas salut et
prévôt a les faveurs de prime abord
j'étais supporter qui le dit mais
comment peut on lire à faire la paix on
y va car les oies frère alors tu as
réussi à chanter eux c'était compliqué
ça fait les pères je flippe est mon club
mais tu vas essayer toi aussi t'as pas
le choix
franchement en vrai la vérité c'est ça
me fait peur la rencontre vous étiez sur
deux roues qui monte avec moi alors tu
restes avec toi oui mais pas derrière
at on a tout de suite le tremplin je
sais pas quand ils vont le faire mais ça
ça donne pas droit
il est sur la piste
pire il fait pour toi etc pour que de
lire à bas prix d'un
mad men a remplacé le bidon quoi on va
tomber à l'eau dépassait une surprise
pour kenji la wka sa mère
[Musique]
o'leary fait attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et un dernier serait pour toi on va s'en
servir
[Musique]
au jeu
quand j'ai même passé et chanter quand
j'ai vu qu'on s'est appréciée de plus en
plus en plus tu sais tu as vu que le de
ventalon t'as pas vu me devant ils ont
cassé en tout cas voilà très très belle
expérience
merci baba quand vous allez fille
journée gros bisous j'espère qu'on va
brasser le faire au but sur youtube très
fort et qui joue toujours le jeu qui
sont formidables et que voilà que j'aime
énormément tout comme kadji sont des
artistes
voilà avec un coeur immense oui